this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality
best selling author and host of an uber
popular podcast
these days is my co-host as we answer
your questions
about your life your money your marriage
your kids your money your career did i
mention your money we'll talk about you
wherever you want to be talked about
right in front of you
hey if you won't do it behind your back
if you call we'll do it right in front
of you that's right
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five and john it's kind of
embarrassing i was walking i do a
mile and a half walk to a three mile to
a five mile run depending on the weather
the weather sucked this morning so i did
a mile and a half walk in the rain
i'm listening to your podcast walking
through my neighborhood
in the dark this morning
laughing out loud uh-oh i was laughing
at your response
to those guys it was absolutely chuckled
down i mean it was classic john deloney
yeah but it was just fun
the podcast is really really good i
appreciate that
dr john deloney you can see you can
listen to him everywhere great podcasts
are listened to from spotify to apple to
google play to uh pandora anything you
want we got it we're everywhere by gosh
it's that easy
and um dr john and rachel cruz will be
doing an event this coming friday night
uh for valentine's day a money and
marriage event and one thing is assured
if it is john and rachel
there will be a lot of content covered
but it will always be
side-splitting funny also these two um
these two are trouble but when you get
them together they're double trouble
it's gonna be a blast we're just running
through the blocking in the rehearsal
part and
i did not know this dave but we've got
screens all throughout our building
i didn't know they were they were
sending those signals all through the
building watching you rehearse
yes listen everybody everything you do
is being recorded just remember it
yes but we were laughing laughing we're
gonna have a blast man it's gonna be a
good time all microphones are on
all microphones are on but now it's
gonna be it's gonna be a blast man
career-ending things happen when you
don't remember that
yeah february 12th at 7 00 p.m
it's 30 is all the money and marriage
event for
uh just in time for valentine's day and
uh
the two biggest things that most people
in america right now are facing
money issues marriage issues and they
always overlap intermingle
and so forth february 12th this coming
friday night 7 p.m
uh phone again go just go to
daveramsey.com
events and you can get everything you
need there get
get get you started and you'll have a
blast phone number here is triple eight
eight two five five two two five duncan
is with us in johnson city hey duncan
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you great man how can we
help
well um i was just wondering should i
sell
one of my vehicles or keep it and
continue
with what i want to do to it so low back
story i am 19 i live with my parents
i have a full-time job and i make about
1500
to 1800 a month i own
two vehicles all paid for
and i have about forty two hundred
dollars in the savings account
and i was wondering should i continue
putting
i have zero debt what are the cars what
are they worth
nothing you want them a project car or
something
uh yes uh one of them
is worth twenty eight hundred dollars
and
the other one is worth four thousand
dollars
tell me about it why do we have to
you're you're working on one's a project
i guess
well both of them are uh running
and i do drive both of them regularly
and um okay then tell me why you have
two cars
well one of them uh i need
because i need to pull a trailer and
one of them also helps me make more
money
on the side the same car the other one
so what are you pulling what kind of
trailer are you pulling
a 12-foot utility trailer what what's
your
side gig
any man yard work okay good for you so
you got
the one on the pickup yes sir a
2004 okay what's the other one
a 1997 toyota 400
and my main ques my question is about
the forerunner
yeah i bought it over a year ago
and since then i've put about 1200 in
parts in it
and i want to drive it to alaska in the
next 16 months
and i'm just wondering would it be
financially
wise to sell it and save up more money
and buy what i want or just build this
thing
into what i want it to be
build it into what you want it to be
what does that mean make it uh talking
about getting big tires on it and
jacking it up
and redoing all the interior and all
that
well making making sure it will make
the big materials survive to drive up
there
okay why don't you rent something to
drive up there
it'd be cheaper
i haven't thought about that so duncan i
this is in my family my wife and i drive
old cars
and whenever we go on a long trip
we rent a really nice car might have
trouble doing that at 19. they usually
want to be 21. that's true
um but yeah that's how i get around man
and not have to worry about it
yeah i i just uh you know it sounds like
you've got two very specific things i
might what
you listen neither one of these cars are
going to cause you to
not be a millionaire when you're 39 okay
there's nothing here that's on the
stupid zone it's just
you know you ask so i'm trying to kind
of think through it with you duncan but
um uh so if you want to keep both of
them and you want to work on it as long
as you're paying cash for it
you're okay okay there's nothing here
that's dying there's nothing out of
control
you can call me up making 20 000 a year
with a 30 000
car in which case i would have had to
tell you to sell your car
but uh you know you're not violating any
of that stuff so you're fine
the only thought that ran through my
mind is i would think there would be a
vehicle that if you sold both of these
and put the money together
that would be a nicer vehicle that would
do both things a nicer truck a newer
truck that will pull your trailer
because you need to go
and take you to alaska that's right um
you know so if you got a four thousand
dollar car and a three thousand dollar
car that'd be like a seven thousand
dollar car
right roughly give or take and we got 4
200 in savings too i think i heard so
you could actually get an 8
000 or 9 000 car i'm probably because
the difference in a four thousand dollar
truck and a ten thousand dollar truck
is not double it's quadruple that's
right it's a hundred thousand miles plus
it's a lot of difference you know if you
buy well and it sounds like you know a
little bit about cars and you're poking
around on
so um it might be that you're trying to
that you've kind of diluted across too
many things and if you piled it up in
one pile you could get one thing that
did everything well
that would be a lot nicer and a lot
better that you pay cash for it would
still be there i would never go over 10
grand in your situation but
but i think you could sell these two put
some money with it and move up to the 9
8 9 10 grand range and really get in a
much better vehicle that's the only
thing that ran through my head
but if you want to keep tinkering with
this highlander whatever wasn't fix it
up
i kept expecting to hear like a 67
mustang you're doing a retro
frame up restoration or something a lot
of guys losing sleep over a 96 4runner
but yeah not
not not many like i got to fix up my
forerunner it doesn't that doesn't come
up much but yeah there is a four runner
gang
that's what i say well they'll come out
now that we said that they are twitter's
coming back i'm sure here they come
twitter
i love you we love you yeah hashtag hate
dave ramsey right now
uh but anyway it's a long one
long line this is the this is the ramsey
[Music]
show
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at 825.5225. so apparently
this is worth discussing
oh great because according to twitter
it's the number one thing on twitter
right now
so i said on fox news this morning uh
that i don't believe in a stimulus check
because if you get 600
or 1400 and it changes your life you
didn't have a life you're already
screwed yeah
and apparently that's news to people
it's it's like apparently i've i have
upset and melted
many snowflakes so the concern is
is what that that 600
changes people's lives i mean honestly i
thought it was a fairly obvious thing
if 600 changes your life your life
really sucks
but i thought you don't have a life
you're screwed i thought both sides have
been upset about that
that that amount well it's not enough
right it's either not enough or why are
we sending it right
yeah well it's not enough or you're not
allowed to talk about not getting it
because apparently
it is freaking life changing and i just
didn't know because i'm an elite boomer
huh i mean it's what
what asinine people are i mean some of
you people have lost your dad blame
minds out there if you really believe
six hundred dollars is going to change
your life you're an idiot
really i mean i've been broke and i
never even then
thought 600 dollars would change my life
back when 600
was a lot of money it's a million
dollars huh you know
i mean really it's i've been broke i
mean
with 600 help yeah if you hand it to me
i'll take it
right but i'm not going to get it
obviously because i don't meet the
income qualifications which i shouldn't
get it
none of you should get it but um but
you're going to
because the government is here to save
the day
it's like a cartoon so so island the
misfit toys up there man
how much of it is is just that dave
which is
it's a it's a signal look how much we're
helping yeah that's all it is
it's look at us we're here to help and
my point is is that they're lying to you
they're not really helping you
right if six hundred dollars or fourteen
hundred dollars completely changes your
life you're
you're screwed yeah you already had
major structural crap
in your life you're struggling with
mental illness you're struggling with a
career problem
you're struggling with uh a work ethic
problem you've got character issues
you've got oh now he's shaming the poor
uh you know which is the other thing i
mean that's absolutely asinine
i'm not doing any of that there's only
one way that your life is i mean you
could have tremendous health
problems that would be it it wouldn't be
shaming anybody it's just
a mathematical arithmetic arithmetic
recognition that 600 is not much money
right and
we've talked about this a lot on this
show that
how many households in america can't
handle a 400
emergency nobody can but again that the
point is
is that you're looking to the government
to fix your life and as long as you wait
on washington dc to fix your life you're
going to suck
your life is going to suck yeah and
that's not poor shaming
no that's shaming stupidity if you
believe
600 is going to change your life you're
stupid
you should be ashamed and so what is
give us like what are people going to do
right now and say
i don't i don't want to be in a
situation where 600 is going to turn
things around for me yeah well you have
to start doing the stuff that we teach
and you say okay what am i going to do
i've got the stuff you deal with on your
show which is what i was thinking of
when i said that sometimes i hear
things on your show people have mental
health issues and and things going on in
their lives and it prohibits them from
making a good life
until they get that fixed gotcha okay
that's what you're saying and keeps them
from making an income
yeah right and sometimes they're on ken
coleman's show and they don't have a
career line
going up and they're making no money
they're starving to death and they
really have got to rework their thoughts
on their career and their job
and they need to make more money right
they need to work more they need to work
in a better place a different place
whatever i've been there yeah you know i
got to change things when they're not
working
right oh and by the way you ought to do
the dave ramsey baby steps right
and save some money and get out of town
it's not if it's when the next thing
comes and get out of that but i mean
there's a whole package here called a
wholeness look at life
a holistic look at your life that says
if 600
fixes your life it doesn't right
it can't to me it feels like a broader
conversation about
something happened and we feel
we feel a right to not have bad things
happen
and the world the bad things are going
to happen and we it's called entitlement
we immediately look to somebody fix it
the government help yeah
right yeah to me it's bigger than a
dollar amount it's an existential crisis
it's an existential issue which is
something happened i'm not going to call
on my neighbors i'm not going to call on
my local church i'm not going to sit
down with my
fix it fix it dave does that make sense
that's the part that's hard for me to
wrap my head around
well and the the problem is and that
the fact that this is trending number
one on twitter is hilarious
but it it's sad because what it
indicates is not that dave ramsey's out
of touch or not not that i'm
not that i'm right or wrong that's not
the point the point is is that
i dare to suggest that the government is
not going to fix your life
that's what i'm getting at it's better
than the dollar amount i dare to suggest
that they can't fix your life yeah
it's up to you to fix your life and
you're not going to have a good life
as long as you wait on them to fix it
right i dared to suggest that
and so snowflakes are melting everywhere
they are going bananas and
uh because i what i did was i i i
basically said
your god is dead
god being your your reliance on the
government solving your problem yeah
your government is your god it is your
provider
in your little existential screwed up
head
and i just said your god the government
is dead
it cannot it cannot come through on its
promises to change your life
the democratic party cannot come through
on their promises to change your life
aoc is not going to change your life
so and neither is the republicans right
well
i want to encourage folks who are stuck
right now well the thing is
if if you recognize that your god is
dead that means you didn't have a god
ah okay and so it's encouraging to me
or it has the potential to be
encouraging in my mind that if you
recognize who god really is
and it is the god of the universe yeah
abba
yep the great i am and it is not the
federal government
and he is your provider and he gives you
instructions that involve you dealing
with you
yes and then he adds the rain in the sun
after you do some planting
right and when we have bats that's not
poor shaming
no it's it's to me it's a it's a
community thing man
you got to have people around you dave
and when we stumble and fall
you've got to plant and there's some
seasons when like you mentioned
i got a health problem that's when
there's other people in your life that
will
help when i went bankrupt it crushed me
yeah emotionally yeah spiritually yep
certainly financially yeah
i got two little babies my marriage is
hanging on by a thread i was broken
and i had people say you know you did
some stupid stuff
and you know what they were right yep
and i didn't sit around getting mad at
them for saying i did stupid stuff i had
to not do stupid stuff anymore that
caused me to get there right
i set myself up for that yep it was my
fault
and then i had other people that came
around and put their arm around me and
said you know what
i know you're hurting and i'm here with
you yep
and that you know and those are the
people of god that do stuff like that
and so that's who's walking with you but
this idea that the government
is that you dare to mention that the
democratic party or the republican party
or congress
or the president is not going to make
your life good
if i dare say that out loud that's
blaspheming
this dead god and man they go
religiously bananas before you tweet
something
i want to challenge everybody before you
instagram put mean things on whatever
go find out the names of your
two neighbors on either side of you and
who live across the street from you
and decide you're going to lean in and
write them a note say hey how's it going
you doing okay yeah
i mean put something get to meet people
put something positive out there that
causes somebody
to move in the right direction and what
i'm trying to do there is saying
you know don't lean on the government
because you've got a long wait
yeah you know if you're waiting on this
to fix your life your life
you're screwed yeah you're because your
philosophy of life is broken
that's right and so it's a there's a lot
of
wisdom and guidance in saying you know
don't believe in a dead god
yeah that that the god of the government
is not going to provide they cannot do
it
they cannot do it all they can give is
small representations of it so they
continue to get your vote
and when you completely sell out to them
emotionally like some of you have
you're screwed especially these days
[Music]
can
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show where we talk about your life and
your money thank you for calling us the
phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five evan is
in harrisburg pennsylvania
hi evan how are you good thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up so
um long story short in september my wife
and i uh welcomed our first child
so yay we have yeah that was the only
good thing i think that really happened
to us in 2020 so that's a plus i guess
but so i um left my job to be
a stay-at-home dad um so we
are blessed to be able to work
off of her you know salary um i'm
working through the baby steps i'm
fairly
new to you i've been listening to you a
lot now recently
i feel like i'm getting hung up on on
baby step two because i kind of feel
like
we're kind of out of order but we have
at least and
we have 14 months left on the lease and
i feel like it's
for me i'm trying to do the budget and
it's kind of really
messing with with my head having that
you know having that 429
payment every month so i was just
looking at what we should
what do you think we should do with
maybe should we buy out the lease or
i was thinking of maybe just taking some
of our savings and
just paying out the rest of the 14
payments and just so i can
utilize that 429 dollars kind of
differently when i'm budgeting them
or what do you think i should do there
because i feel like what are you
planning on doing
with the car at the end of the 14 months
well that's a thing uh my wife is
currently working from home
so there's a chance that even when this
is up she could still be
working still from home so in that case
we would just need
my car that's it's paid for and
everything so
we wouldn't necessarily need two cars
maybe so that's the thing too i was like
if we don't need
two cars then maybe we could you know
just get away with mine for a while
what's your household income uh
uh gross is 87 000. how much other debt
do you have other than this car
uh just a house that's it the car in the
house
yeah and how much is in savings
uh i have we have a thirty thousand
dollar
emergency fund okay so you're doing this
out of order you know that right
yes yeah okay and then we have uh 38
000 in our savings for regular so you
can call the car company and ask them
what the early buyout
on the car is that's the payoff balance
today
that will consist of the remaining of
your payments plus
uh the buyout number at the end minus a
discount for cost of capital
and so uh there's a number you would buy
it for at the end of 14 months
and then that number plus the 429 for 14
uh is the second number it's that total
of those two the buyout should be less
than that total did you get that already
yeah yes is it early if i just wanted to
buy it right now
then as 26 100
write a check today and pay the car off
okay and keep the car
okay you say keep it okay let's pretend
you had a 26 000
car loan on your car and you called me
up with 30 000
in your bank account that's what i would
tell you to do isn't it
you knew that yeah yeah
now if you want to sell your car later
and move down to one car
you can but you can afford this car with
your income
and you have the money i'm i'm gonna pay
it off and keep it and move on to baby
step three make sure i have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
and then i'm going to start my
retirement and go from there
but you're trying to work your plan and
hang on to the savings not our plan
and so you just got to decide which
place you want to be um
you know make a decision or get off the
ladder here uh
and that's what i would do if i woke up
in your shoes because
i know that if you follow through on
what we teach this is the shortest
distance
between where you are and a level of
wealth that puts you in a position to be
outrageously generous
works that way dr john deloney is my
co-host today if you want to talk about
your life
and things that are happening in your
relationships and
so forth jump in the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
danny's in grand forks north dakota hi
danny how are you
i'm doing well how are you doing today
better than i deserve what's up
oh well uh so an interesting
opportunity's come up recently
where there's a potential where i could
be working in a six-figure job
but it would require a move um and me
and
my family are are very well firmly
planted in this area
we planted a church recently and i
worked two other jobs as well
um and so i guess i was curious what
your thoughts were on something like
that because that
from my from my standpoint in life going
up that much in a yearly income through
one job is is very
i never dreamed it'd even be something
that could potentially be on the table
what's the job uh via project management
is it something you love to do that you
want to do
yeah i've been i i'm good at management
you know it's something that i've done
uh for for eight years um but you know
my calling is to help and serve people
and
speak life into people's lives you know
so i work
full-time in the fitness industry and
then i pastor part time
and then i work with people with mental
disabilities part-time as well
do you have kids yes i have two kids and
a wife
so it sounds like you already know the
answer do you feel guilty about not
taking a six-figure job
yes sounds like you don't want the job
sounds like you don't want to move
yeah so you got permission to not take
the job man thank you
yeah i i agree with that the other side
of it is yeah seasonally man is this a
moment in your life when
man you could really bite the bullet for
four or five years and
work really hard in something i i don't
always buy the
my my let me put it this way i'm i'm
like you
i have a i feel like i'm good at helping
folks
i've done that behind closed doors at 2
a.m with
police departments i've done that with
college kids i've done that with college
kids parents
i've done that with adults at my house
now i do it on the radio
it's a different assignment but the
mission stays the same so if you care
and love helping people
you can do that as a project manager you
can also do that
volunteer at a local church or with
people with disabilities right
you can do all those different things
and so dave i struggle with this
this calling i've got to only do this
thing
i think you can do your life mission in
a number of different places a number of
different a number of different roles
and if it gives you 5 10 15 25 hours a
week back to your kids and your wife
that's an invaluable thing right yeah
i i i give you permission to do either
one and i'll just
echo what john's saying what ran through
my mind is
is that um somehow you've gotten in your
head
that in order to be helping people you
have to be broke
no and i have to be i have to be doing
personal training
and be a minister part-time because in
business you can't be helping people
actually
that could be the biggest mission field
the biggest ministry
that you've ever had in your life
managing projects and leading young
people
and uh i mean you could speak into their
lives in so many ways
i do every day with our person with our
thousand people on this team here
um it is one of the biggest ministries
that i have is the leadership role here
at ramsey not just on the radio
and so um you know the idea that they
you know you can you can be a restaurant
owner and be in ministry
you can uh so it's just it's a mindset
of how you get there
i kind of think though you don't want to
leave grand forks
that's also in the mix that we drove
past pretty quick so
this is both a career and a location
thing
the only thing i would challenge you is
don't turn this down
because it's not holy and what you're
doing is holy
right that's all i'm saying that would
be a mistake
but if you don't want to do that thing
and you don't want to live in that city
and the only thing taking you there's
money you're going to be miserable
don't go do it don't go do it because i
mean money does not solve everything
dude i mean if you eat enough lobster it
tastes like soap
i mean you just get more money at some
point so
uh but but also you don't you know you
don't have to work for a non-profit to
be holy right
uh you don't have to be small time to be
holy
your work can be holy when you decide it
is and you have a
other centered matrix that you're
looking at it through
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this coming friday night
he and rachel cruz will be doing a money
and marriage
live stream february the 12th at 7 p.m
tickets are only 30 if you're a ramsey
plus member it is free for you to watch
if you want to have your marriage
impacted
your money impacted john and rachel you
will be laughing and crying and
everything else
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best possible deal all
right today's question comes from doug
in missouri i'm struggling with how much
to help my son
and daughter-in-law financially they are
both mid-thirties and she recently
became a veterinarian with about four
hundred thousand dollars in student
loans which has severely affected their
ability to buy a house
or save any money financially i could
easily help them as i have several
millions saved but i want them to figure
this out themselves
however i feel guilty for not helping
them both my wife and i are afraid it's
going to be the wrong decision
i need some perspective as i'm just not
sure what the best thing to do
is
dave do you know how much vets make i
don't
more than a lot of doctors do they i
mean a good
i don't know how long she's been in
practice or where she is but 100 to 200.
okay so if my
yeah man if you take out 400 000 to
become a doctor whether a doctor of a
person or a doctor of
a animal i think you got to work
together and figure it out
you got to get a long-term plan i've
never been in a position like this
parents in you've got more perspective
on that than i do
i want folks who who signed on a dotted
line
that said um i
agree to that you're going to help me
get my education and i promise to pay
you back
i felt an obligation to pay people back
even when i didn't fully understand what
i was signing at the end of the day i
had to look at the paper and say
i signed it i borrowed it i got to
figure it out so that's where my bent is
um but i've never been in the position
where i could help somebody to a tune of
i could wipe this out one afternoon and
take care of it for them so i get that
temptation for my kids
um yeah but i'm hesitant to do that
what do you think i think most people go
too far one direction or the other okay
like he just writes the check and they
don't feel any pain
and they just be bop off into the sunset
right
or he does nothing and they languish for
years
when he could have stroked a check and
bailed him out
so um the only thing i've been able to
figure out that's kind of
in the middle is
if you're going to get my money you're
going to get my coaching
it comes with strings there you go and
my coaching is nothing to do with me
it's not about controlling
yeah it's about you're going to be on a
path that i agree with
or i'm not financing it right and so
if you could get them on a strike on a
tight budget they're not out
spending money like they're crazy
they're like they're in congress or
something they're
they're you know they're on a budget
they're working hard they're making
progress
and you agreed to match
everything they throw the to the student
loan
uh as long as they're on a path right
now if they're paying 10
on the student loan and they make 350
000 no they're not on a path
but if they're putting 150 000 on that
student loan or 200 000 on it
and they're going to do that in 18
months or something and they're going to
live on beans and rice and they're going
to do the stuff
then you know they got their engine
running i'll pour some gas in their
engine
i like that okay so no new cars no big
house yeah
they're working a plan that i think they
should work right
which is what they would have to do if i
wasn't there is dad right
and this guy i'm putting the dad's shoes
on with this guy right but if i wasn't
there what would they have to do well
they'd be
dirt under their fingernails man i mean
they'd be scratching and clawing right
and so uh but if there's a difference
between abandonment
on one end of the spectrum enabling
right on the other in the spectrum which
is just like oh it's just not fair look
at the student loans we're just going to
write them a check and just forgive all
their student loans and all this crap's
happening in washington right
and it's sad that the girl's got student
loans and i don't want her to i feel bad
for it if you've got student loans out
there i feel bad for you
but i don't want the government to
forgive them right i want you to work
through them and i want us in the
society to come around you and i want
them to stop making the student loans
before they start talking about
forgiving them by the way that's a side
issue too
but um anyway i said that on our
borrowed uh future podcast and
didn't stir up near as much as when i
said it on fox this morning but the uh
uh
but anyway the the point being that yes
i want to help them
but i want to help them if they're
getting
really invested in helping themselves if
someone is not
doing good things for themselves and you
finance that that is not helping them
correct
that is harming enabling them that's
giving a drunk a drink that's buying a
cocaine addict his next bag
right you know it's like oh you're a
weed addict here i'll buy a bag
you know i mean that's not helpful to
finance
misbehavior finance behaviors that
aren't causing them to win
but if they're moving in the right
direction and i can come alongside them
and say hey
what if you did this this and this and
if you did those three things
and you really play through i'll do this
to add put some gas in your little
engine
right but let's get the little engine
going down the little engine that could
right
going down the tracks here and then i
will join hands with them
but you know another example of that is
i had a friend that's very wealthy and
he
refused to pay for a dime of his kids
college because he had to work his way
through
and so he appreciated his education
because he had dirt under his
fingernails and he had a scratching claw
to get his education
and he was he's worth it probably a
billion dollars wouldn't pay for a dime
of his kids college
and um i i respect that i understand his
reasoning
and i mean he's hardcore all right uh i
paid for 100 of my kids college yeah
but i did not pay for a 100 of kids
college who were misbehaving
right they weren't they're they were
walking with god they weren't
down there sleeping around all over the
campus they weren't doing drugs
you know they weren't drunk in their bed
and missing classes you know
so they were functional students right
bringing home grades
walking a lifestyle and a life that i
approved of
i'll finance that right well they need
to get a job that is their job then
is behaving you know and and in that
world that's a big job
and i want to talk to folks that are my
age that are
younger than me that are thinking about
college
if you take money from somebody else
they get to speak into how you spend it
that's how that works
and going back to our controlling no
that is a part of the
of the that's a part of the agreement if
i give you money
to go to college if i give you money to
pay off your student loans
i get to speak into how you spend it
because it's mine it's a gift yeah right
and it's this it goes back to that got a
guy calling me from michigan one time he
said
my son has decided he's going to an
expensive school that we can't afford so
it's going to mean student loan debt
what do i do
my son told me this is what he's doing
and i said well it starts way back when
your son started telling you
this is a six-year-old problem this is a
18 year old problem my son doesn't tell
me stuff i tell him stuff
that's how that works especially when
it's me writing the freaking checks
so i'm going to tell you where my where
your little butt's going to school
if i'm paying for it that's right and so
we don't need to visit colleges i'll
help you with this
that's right that's right you know
because i mean you can visit two
there's two here that are in your budget
you can go look at them i don't even
need to go with you
and so you don't fall in love with the
beauty of the college campus and go 250
000
in debt to get a degree in left-handed
puppetry but it goes it goes back to
that conversation we're talking about
a segment ago i want everyone to
understand
when you take money from somebody
you're also taking whatever else they're
going to hand you
right whatever else they're going to
demand of you whatever else they're
going to make you do
well and you know when we start talking
about you know we'll parlay this this
guy the answer the question for me is
if they will do smart things help them
help them do smart things
but if they man yeah i don't care if
you're a veterinarian i don't care if
you're a surgeon okay if you're a
medical doctor if you have 400 thousand
dollars in debt you're going to live
like a freshman in college yep until you
get this stuff paid off
i don't care what people in your heart
tell me about buying a recliner sit on
the bean bag yup
i don't care what your partners are
driving at your at your veterinary
clinic
you drive your old car to get this stuff
paid off man yep
exactly and if you're waiting around the
government to fix it let me tell you
what happens
okay they announced you can probably
tell me
it's probably a little well it's 15
years ago roughly the federal government
announced that
the private student loan forgiveness
program oh man
if you work 10 years in an underserved
situation
and you pay your bill on time we'll
forgive the remaining of your debt that
is still there at the end of 10 years
dave i worked with these law students
175 439 people have applied for that
175 000 people applied for that
to date three thousand of the hundred
and seventy five thousand three thousand
one hundred seventy four have gotten it
i worked with so many people waiting on
the government to fix your life
including the discussions that are going
on up there right now
your life's gonna suck because you're
worshiping a dead god
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
this is the ramsey shop you can be
intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author is my co-host today as we talk
about your life
which is what he talks about on the dr
john deloney show or the john doloni
show what is it
it's the doctor we spent um weeks
long creative brilliant people in here
deciding what to name it
we came up with the dr john dolone show
sometimes the most obvious things are
the answer man talk about tip your nose
on that one man
the doctor john deloney show and you
need to tune into it on podcasts
everywhere
it is absolutely fabulous i listen to it
every day when it comes out and um the
the stuff you get into man there's some
deep
life issues and some squirrely people
out there some people's children
can i tell can i tell you this it was a
heartbreaking moment i
it was about three or four weeks into
shooting the show
and we shoot multiple episodes a week so
there's got got in there quite a bit and
somebody called
a question and i just stopped and said
why are you asking me
and davis was a haunting response and i
think this is in
is all over the country right now she
said i got nowhere else to go
and that made me it broke my heart right
people
got nobody they're gonna call a guy they
don't know on the radio right
like you're the guy i trust right now
and um so
yeah the whole goal of that show man is
to teach people how to reconnect
with their neighbors and with their
local communities and um just learn how
to be a person again man we just lost it
we've lost it
yeah well i the the advice is uh
stellar and uh so you guys check it out
and you can call in today and he'll talk
to you
right here at triple eight eight two
five five two
two five you know the answer is more
than just
i got nobody else the answer is the
other stuff she heard you do
made her trust you oh of course yeah
yeah yeah you know that that's what
really happened
right steve is with us steve's in new
york city hi steve how are you
hey dave and john thanks for taking my
call i appreciate it sure what's up
uh well recently retired about a year
now 53 years old
i have my work retirement but uh my mom
had passed away
uh 18 months ago we sold her house
and i inherited a 150 000 that way
now it's up to me to uh to invest it
through mutual funds i'm
not super duper comfortable with it and
i have some ideas
but uh i know i don't know between
regular mutual funds tax deferred mutual
funds
uh do i go all in with the 150 or do i
piecemeal it
do you have any dad um
currently just my one son's college
she's a senior
how much do you own that uh
we probably owe another 35 000 for him
okay we need to set that aside right uh
yeah we have that
and we have some savings okay and so
there's no debt associated with the
college you just have an obligation
correct okay do you have a home mortgage
uh not any longer no good for you good
for you
okay couple of things on investing um
let's start at the top
number one you don't invest in things
that you don't understand you never
invest in things because some goob on
the radio like me said do it
or some good on the internet that's even
worse said do it
okay so you understand it
the bible says in the multitude of
counsel there is safety and what that
means is you get some experts around you
to
give you advice and the advice is not
that you follow the expert the advice is
so that you understand
something you didn't understand before
so your financial people need to have
the heart of a teacher
so that when you sit down with your
financial person and you get up and
leave you need to know something you
didn't know before you sit down
every time every time
i spent an hour and a half in my office
yesterday
with our chief digital officer
and three of our top uh senior
uh tech guys and they were trying to
teach me
oh jeez that's why you're in such a
great mood today
about a digital about our digital
platform
and i don't i do not have to be a
digital expert to be the ceo of this
digital company
but i do have to grasp the vernacular
and i do have to grasp
enough of it to help them to make wise
decisions under
their help so the multitude of counsel
these experts are in my office
teaching me about my company
yesterday in this case they're teaching
you about your money
that you inherited from your the passing
of your parent
right and so you're gonna gather that up
you do not have to have an mba in
finance
in order to make easy financial
decisions basic investing decisions now
so rule number one is you don't do it
unless you understand it rule number two
is you put somebody in your life that
has the heart of a teacher
you can click smart vester pro at
daveramsey.com or smart investor
and find the person in your area we
recommend they don't work for us
they pay us an endorsement fee and they
have to agree to approach
your investing the way that we teach and
with the heart of a teacher
i personally invest steve inside my
retirement accounts
in four types of mutual funds growth
growth and income aggressive growth
and international outside of retirement
accounts
those funds all create taxes each year
as they grow that's a problem
there's two ways to avoid that with your
150 000
my preference is and the one that i
personally do is i
invest in mutual funds growth stock
mutual funds
that have what's called a low turnover
ratio now you ready for the teaching
part
okay here we go if you buy
a rental house for two hundred thousand
dollars and it goes
up in value to three hundred thousand
dollars and you still own it
you do not owe taxes on that one hundred
thousand in growth because you've not
sold the house agreed
correct so you've got capital gains
growth
but you don't have any taxes because
you've not sold it
stock is the same way if a share of
stock goes from fifty dollars to seventy
dollars
you don't pay taxes on that twenty
dollar gain until you sell it
same is true inside a mutual fund the
turnover ratio is when they sell the
stock
inside the mutual fund if it has a
ninety
turnover ratio that means almost all the
stocks get sold
every year and so all those gains are
going to be taxable every year
if they have a five percent if they have
a five percent turnover ratio which is a
low
turnover ratio that means you're not
going to pay taxes on the increase in
value
until you sell the mutual fund because
they aren't selling the stocks
inside the mutual funds hardly at all
much like that rental house or that
share of stock
did that make sense it definitely did so
uh that low turnover what number am i
looking at is it
under 10 you want an under 10 turnover
ratio
under 10 percent yeah because anything
that turns over
the gain is they're going to send you a
tax bill on the gain every year
every every year yes okay so you want it
to not turn over hardly at all
so that it only grows without taxes
until you sell it
now if you hold it a year when you sell
it you're going to be taxed at
capital gains rate 15 rather than
the ordinary income rate 30 percent 40
percent
so the tax rate the tax rate is also
much lower for you
so it's tax efficient two different ways
one is you're not taxed till you sell it
and two is when you do sell it it's
taxed at a capital gains rate
your smartvestor pro can help you with
every bit of that
and finish teaching you what i did in
five minutes but that's the whole thing
all you gotta do is learn some basic
things like that they're not this is not
rocket science
you just have somebody knows their stuff
and they show you how and then you know
your stuff
so you do it smart
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
today the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five
two two five mike is in tampa florida
hey mike what's up
hey dave hey dr do you think stick from
the call how are you guys today
better than we deserve how can we help
um
i need a little help with the tie
breaker for your favorite question um
we are baby step two um and i'm debating
on selling my vehicle
um we are we saw the car camera on my
wife's car as well
and student loans how much in student
loans
student loans is 30 000. what do you owe
on your cars
i have 12 000 on my wife's car and i owe
32 000 on like
my expedition and what's your household
income
i make 140 000 plus vehicle allowance
my mileage rate and then my wife makes
50 000 and i have
two side hustles that bring in about 20
000 a year
so 250 grand about that yes
okay and um any other debt other than
these three things on your mortgage
um we actually went we don't have a
mortgage we decided to wait until
we got out of debt and uh no we paid off
all of our credit cards we paid off all
of the
medical debt already we are just now on
to the vehicles and the student loans
okay and uh you're fired up about this
and she's not as fired up
yeah well i drive over a thousand miles
a week guys so i i work from miami to
jacksonville i'm on the road all day and
she's a little concerned that if i
saw the vehicle get something cheaper it
will break down and my vehicle
uh allowance my local mileage generally
covers the car payment and
the gas i'm on the other hand on the
fence because
i see debt going way faster okay
all right well you get the vehicle
allowance whether you have a car payment
or not
so comparing it to the car payment is a
is a fool's trap don't get caught in
that trap
but um you can afford these cars and you
can afford this debt
you can afford to pay off this debt i
mean you got uh seventy four thousand
dollars worth of debt making 250 ought
to be debt free in a year
that was the idea yes under 15 months
okay now let's pretend let's pretend
you're there
so that's probably what you ought to do
by the way okay i think i think your
wife wins the argument
um as long as you're both on board with
doing beans and rice and getting out of
debt in a year
yes sir okay the second thing is this
you need to drive because you are
destroying
the value of whatever vehicle you drive
you need to drive the least possible
expensive car for purposes of your
business that will get
the job done now let's put that in air
quotes get
the job done the definition of getting
the job done when i make 250 000
a year i don't need to be driving a
freaking smart car
i'll be in a chiropractor's office as
much time as you spend in a car
you don't need to be driving a piece of
crap and broke down on the side of the
highway
okay so get the job done is a nice
comfortable reliable vehicle
knowing that whatever i spend on it i
might as well pile that up in hundred
dollar bills in the front yard and light
it on fire because you're going to
destroy
the value of whatever you drive agreed
yes sir
agreed and so next time i buy a car it's
probably not going to be a 40
000 car to destroy
yeah absolutely some decision yeah no
i'm not picking on you i'm just saying
going forward
that's what i would do because you just
say i'm a road warrior even if you want
a nice car in the driveway
and a road warrior car for driving that
i'm destroying
i'm okay with that
yeah that's what that's what i thought
of i thought i was getting like a
smaller car and she said that i would be
miserable and i
agree you said the same thing yeah i
just don't want you in a piece of crap
that's not reliable and i also don't
want you in something that's
you know you spend a lot of time in a
car it needs to ride good it needs to
drive well good
it needs to be um you know it's it's a
road car i mean
but you don't you know you wouldn't
drive a you you wouldn't go by a hundred
thousand dollar mercedes
and turn it into a ten thousand dollar
mercedes every three years
because that's what you're doing because
that's what you're doing so
that's the balance here you just gotta
it's a business decision
what you put on the road now you may
reach a point with your income
and your wealth that you have a road car
and a weekend driver
that's a that's your cool car that's at
home it's a 40 or a 50 000
car that's paid for sitting in your
driveway and then you get a brand new
what camry or avalon or something to
your own there you go yeah
and just get you you know two-year-old
camry and our uh you know a nice honda
accord loaded up or
whatever i don't care what it is i mean
uh okay you know caddy yeah those
caddies are pretty nice they're doing
good
uh just knowing you're gonna burn the
depreciation off that sucker
to the ground whatever it is and you
know what you're looking for there is
like you're looking for gas mileage too
yeah because you're you're running the
wheels you're just running up down the
road thousand miles man i mean this
you start putting 50 000 miles a year on
a car pretty much
gone right i mean even if you take care
of it you can get a lot of life out of
it but my point is the
value goes away right quickly yep
because nothing destroys value like
mileage
so um that that or you know driving it
up through the field
yes jumping creeks or you know stuff
like that that's the john dillon with
my cars might be some rednecks sitting
here that have done something like that
i don't
know anybody like that personally but
they're in this room all of us
okay josh is with us josh in springfield
illinois hey josh how are you
dave what's up hey man how can we help
hey yeah my wife and i are having a good
heart at this agreement
we've got all our debt paid off except
for a semi-truck in our house
so i was wondering you kind of break the
tie here this is tie breaker hours tie
breaker hour man
you guys are setting us up guys what do
you want to do josh
i want to pay the big truck off because
it's a liability what's the balance
93 000 what about the house 60 000.
how much money you got in savings
now last year dave i put 160 000 miles
on this semi truck how much money you
got in savings
oh 35 000.
and what's your household income uh my
10.99 last year was uh
for 2020 was 170 000.
yeah but that's before expenses right
that's
uh the only expense taken out of that
would be fuel so 170 000 to my bank
account
my truck payments about 2100 a month
what's the fuel
uh the fuel i would say we was around
about 50 or 60
000 in fuel okay she made 120 does she
work outside the home
no okay so if we have 120 000 and 35 000
and we have 150 000 in debt how quickly
can we pay both of them off
both of those we pay the house off in
less than a year both of them should be
gone
in three years agreed i agree
okay so we're really not arguing about
much except just
which one's going to be in the third
year and which one's going to be in the
first year
correct so which one does your wife want
to do first she won't do the house first
she she wants to pay the house off i
want to pay this because it says
depreciation
yeah but you get the appreciation either
way
you get the depreciation either way and
either way they're both done in three
years
okay so the only thing you're losing is
not the concept of getting it paid off
at all
the only thing you're losing is whether
it's done in the second and third year
or whether it's done in the first and
second year
does that make sense yes so this is now
marital advice
so now i want you to go home tonight i
want you to
hey josh i want you to take a knee
i want you to say honey i was wrong
i was wrong and i love you and you're
beautiful and we're gonna get this house
paid off for you
and as long as we can both agree that
we're gonna play all the way through and
be done with both in three years i'm i'm
with you let's go to the house first
you didn't really lose much you just
lost a little bit of time on your
argument
you lost the argument but that's okay
it's better to lose the lose the battle
and win the war my brother
you know she's sitting right next to me
laughing at me
the good news is you guys have a great
marriage and you're having a fun
discussion about how many different ways
you can become wealthy
these are lots of discussions couples
never get to have i'm so proud of y'all
that's impressive that's cool man and i
love the uh
the sense of humor about it all if you
can keep that about some of these
conversations yeah man
that's so bad and we're having a
discussion about how fast we're going to
get everything
paid off right and all of it is within
three years there's no negative in this
discussion nobody loses if yeah
your your mortgage is paid off in three
years or 12 months
yeah yeah that's a cool place to be
actually you're going to take something
at 35 000. well you got to have that as
emergency fund probably but if that's
not your emergency fund if that's extra
savings
only 60 owed on that house you're
probably going to be out of bed before
christmas
he owes her a nice dinner tonight too
that's what happens when you lose the
bet
sharon used to say i'll bet you pizza
and we both got pizza
everybody wins every time
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney my co-host today here on
the ramsey show this is dave ramsey your
host
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
jeffrey and nicoletta are here hey guys
how are you good are you dave how much
debt have you two paid off
49 000. wow how long did that take
23 months good for you where do you guys
live
we live in tampa but in lakeland florida
okay
yeah i've been to lakeland several times
very cool beautiful area
fun yeah southeast university i spoke
there at some events several times yep
that's where i went for undergrad and my
master's yeah they had a big
used to have a big leadership thing down
there and bring in a bunch of outside
speakers and i was one of them a couple
of times
awesome very cool very nice how long
what was your range of income during
this 23 months so the first year was 50k
to then we finish off with 75. good for
you
well done what do you guys do for a
living i'm a maintenance technician for
a logistics company down there
and i'm a mental health therapist very
good what kind of debt was the 49
000 so i had a 3 000 car loan
and then our the rest was our student
loans he points at her
mostly mine i did both yeah you kind of
yeah the thumb was
you were hitchhiking for a minute and
then you went back yeah okay well played
man
that's a man married to a therapist
right there
all right 49 000 in student loans and
car loans how old
are you two i'm 27. i just turned 25.
how long have you been married
two years okay so this was the first
order of business when you got married
then
so tell me how that goes down because
most married couples don't start and go
hey let's get out of debt what happened
so i think my
my journey started with him when i was
younger because my parents were normal
everyone just had that and i saw the
stress that normal cost
and that was probably when i was 14 or
15 and then
fast forward to probably 22 and i went
through the class
with mary beth up in calvary irwin i
lived in pittsburgh before i moved back
to lakeland to be with her because she
got a free masters
ah and i went through the class and also
you mean financial peace university yeah
okay all right and i was like this is
how i wanted us to handle our money
because
just makes sense and and then we got
engaged and he gave me one of your books
and i read it and i was like yeah let's
do it and so
right when we got married we started
right away just like that
y'all are just too easy i went to class
and she read the book said let's do it
there's no big fight nobody had to get
killed that's a brave guy to give a
self-help book for an engagement gift
brother
that's a brand new therapist yeah she
knew how to breathe it out just
wow exactly there wasn't an exercise
book or something in there too
okay good for you yeah okay all right
just the money good you guys are fun i'm
so proud of you well done who were your
biggest cheerleaders
we had a bunch of friends we had um it
was the social aspect was
difficult because some friends were like
super encouraging but they didn't
understand what we were doing but
they love us and so they were like great
and there's other ones that
we actually have friends that just
became debt-free last week
and so um people like that were super on
board and came alongside us and checked
in
and um we remember during the ends
something with our car happened and we
just felt super discouraged because it
was
the very last leg of it and we texted
two of our friends who were really on
board with us like i
literally sent a voice memo like crying
like explaining how frustrated this was
and
they literally both sent voice memos
back praying for us and just like you
guys can do it you're so close and
that was literally the last thing we
needed to get through it was awesome
that is very cool yeah that is very cool
you know
john honestly i i see this a lot more
because i used to say like who is the
one that made fun of you
and who are your biggest cheerleaders
and um
ten years ago somebody in their 20s
doing their debt free screaming i said
you know who are you you know
well we have friends that didn't
understand they made fun of us right
this generation the 20s are like they
don't understand but they love us
it's because it's like do it anyway you
do you bro this 20th generation is
awesome
it's an awesome generation they're so
enjoy i don't even like you and what
you're doing but do it anyway i love you
you know it's just like they're just
it's just it's great
it's so cool very cool what do you tell
people the key to getting out of details
i think being obedient to the lord is
like putting your tie first like you say
and allowing god to work pretty much
yeah and i would definitely say
discipline
um the people who want what we have and
see our results
it's funny because we'll tell them and
they're like well what about this or
what about that and i'm like you just
don't care you just this is the priority
and so you just do it and
it's like no excuses and don't take it
personal when your husband tells you no
to going to target
and things like that so um
it might have happened she just stared a
hole through you man no but i needed it
and
knowing we're on the same page like at
first i did take it personal like
well this is annoying but he's like no
like we're a team this is what it is and
i would do it to him when he wanted
snacks you know like unnecessary things
and so
um it really is just being on the same
team and just not making excuses just
seeing
seeing what it could look like long term
that was like the big thing for us yeah
just like maintaining context like this
is only for a little bit and then we do
whatever we want later
yeah live like no one else later you can
live and give like no one else
absolutely so nicoletta from a therapist
viewpoint
did you did you recognize that you guys
early
in your relationship are setting i mean
you're setting serious grooves
in how you process information as a
couple how you go when at things as a
couple
the money piece just happened to be
where you were doing it yeah but this
was a huge
exercise relationally wasn't it for sure
yeah and another hard thing that
was a part of our journey was social
life because for me
i'm super extroverted and we started to
not get invited to things
and i'm like they don't want to be
friends with us anymore because we don't
want to go out and spend money on this
and this and this and whatever they're
doing
we live close to disney and so um
i think for us too together it was a
growing
part because we were like realizing we
can't take the stuff personally like
they still love us they're still our
friends
some like we're super creative and like
hey let's just have a game night because
we know you guys are trying to save
money
and i feel like our community helped us
be a team
too because we realized like sometimes
it is just going to be you and i
and like no one else is going to get it
and then our community around us really
helped us too so
in our marriage it was really awesome
because i feel like we grew
it just extended into everything else
just super important yeah it's powerful
it's
godly dude my wife and i are having
those conversations now we've been
together almost quarter century so good
for you guys man thank you
just being able to see hey this is just
seasonal this is just gonna be hard for
a couple of two or three years and then
right
it's always that and then and dave i
have to just say what
these two figured it out and we've been
talking about this this whole segment
it's both end it's the dreamer
it's the prayer it's the it we're gonna
work out it's gonna work out
and then there's also the you got to do
it every day
and every day and every day and every
day it's both and right
you got to have that big picture and
that discipline you got to feel it and
then go do it right
and those those rotate and supporting
each other every other day right
one day it's like i just need a dream
man because i can't get up and do it
again
exactly and then vice versa well but you
got such a healthy view
of your interaction with your community
that you got from your community what
you needed
they're awesome that was pretty cool
that's cool man
got a copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday
millionaires we're also going to give
you a uh ticket to the live stream that
is coming up this friday night with dr
john deloney and
rachel cruz the money and marriage event
we managed to have them on the show
actually yeah
you really needed to interview them on
how to do it that's exactly right
february 12th 7 pm gonna give you all of
that as our gift we're so proud of you
guys congratulations
well done all right jeffrey and
nicoletta from lakeland florida
49 000 paid off in 23 months making 50
to 75
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're
[Applause]
this is how it's done
both ends you know we've been talking
about getting you into a financial peace
university
small group and that the accountability
and the encouragement from the small
group was the magic sauce
of financial peace university it happens
inside ramsey plus these days
i've been talking about that for 20
years and you come along in your show
and you're constantly telling people
as they're going to work on these mental
health things that they've got in their
lives they've got to be in community
friends or everything everything friends
are
everything and we've lost a lot of that
during this pandemic and you guys got to
reach back out and
pull that back into your lives in order
to have successful lives
scratch and claw do whatever you got to
do to get reconnected man
you're just fine the check won't save
you in the mail your friends
will oh you got to have people
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today here at ramsey solutions
we want to do
millions and millions of times what we
just experienced with that debt-free
screen we want to transform so many
lives
that disruption spreads like
wildfire across our country whether it's
in the mental health space with dr
john or the money space with
some of the other ramsey personalities
career space with ken coleman
marriage space money space we want to
disrupt
and transform so many lives imagine a
world where it's weird to have a student
loan debt
where the majority of people pay cash
for their cars where it's
kind of looked down on to have a credit
card like the credit card is the
cigarette
of the financial world
where you actually have the relationship
skills to work through
the conflict because you've spent time
in john's materials
imagine a world where most people are
that way
that's a transforming thing for our
nation and that's what we're trying to
do
uh that's a level of disruption to this
toxic culture
and that's what ramsay solutions is
doing that's why we've got a thousand
people in our company working together
to create
products and digital products and
services and
digital services to help people with
this transformation
with the goal of disrupting the toxic
culture
because this culture is messed up you
guys you know that
you don't want to be married like the
culture you don't raise kids like the
culture
you don't want to handle money like the
culture you don't want to run a business
or leadership like the culture
it's messed up and um
we're in the process of changing that if
you want to join us on this crusade
we are on the hunt for folks to join our
team
we intend to hire 350 more people this
year and that includes software
engineers
ruby on rails folks java c-sharp
front-end technologies
ux designers seo folks content
specialists
senior developers
you want to write code you want to lead
people that are writing code and
building digital products
for things that are changing people's
lives well that's what we do
oh and by the way we don't work 180
hours a week
we work 40 hours a week and we go home
with a rare exception of when we have a
project deadline
but you walk through this place at six
o'clock at night there's nobody in here
right john
or somebody's going to say hey what are
you doing here what are you doing here
you need to go be with your family you
need to go home
you can go home hug your babies you know
good if you're no good at home you're
not good and that's not true in the
digital world
most the time technology folks the dev
you know if you're a developer
24 7 360. they're just going to burn you
up man
you're just a robot they're going to eat
you alive and
uh and you don't even know what the code
you're writing is doing
it could be doing harm in some cases
so uh you want to find out about the
jobs that are available here
we're on a crusade to change this world
i mean and that's not just
cheese factory that's the truth check
out daveramsey.com click on the dave's
hiring tab over on the right hand side
of the homepage
you can see all of our opportunities
they're not all digital there's all
kinds of opportunities but
tons and tons of senior dev positions
and
uh platform folks ruby on rails folks
java c-sharp seo
tons of that product uh
uh you know product managers i mean
there's everything
uh pm ones twos threes we've we've got
some serious stuff rolling out of here
you think about the products that we put
out i would you like to have been
working on every dollar when we launched
that
or when we iterated every day yeah
or ramsey plus or some of the other
things we're doing it's pretty
pretty fun stuff so check us out dave's
hiring at daveramsey.com
luca's with us in san antonio hey luca
welcome
to the ramsey show how can we help
how are you doing today thank you so
much for taking my call sure
what's up um i'm calling because i am 28
years old
i have a wife and i have two little
girls and i'm looking to
start getting into becoming a real
estate agent but i don't want to be one
of those flying balls you know
and i just want to know what advice you
would have or any thoughts you would
have
for getting into this in 2021 uh we have
no debt
based on my wife's school in all cash
and we own our vehicles the only thing
is that we live in an apartment
we don't have a house yet and that's
kind of wanted to know what your
thoughts were
i'm becoming a real estate agent what do
you uh what do you make a year
um this past year together with my wife
and i we only made forty thousand
dollars
okay what do you make and what does she
make
okay she makes so she makes um thirty 32
000
and this year since i lost my job in
2020
i was really working with immigrant
shelters and kids weren't coming so they
laid us off so
i was kind of here and there with jobs
throughout the year trying to kind of
bring in what i could
so just total was 40 thousand but before
i was seven years
the social service is making about
thirty six thousand dollars okay and but
today what are you making
at this moment okay today um
i'm making 30 annually will be 34 000
okay so you've gotten another job yes i
have another job right now okay
you said you're 28 correct 28.
yes sir good great well i think you got
a wonderful goal
uh why is it you want to get in the real
estate business
you know i've i've um i just i love
i've done the church thing i've been in
church kind of i've done the leadership
stuff i love making
um impacts with people and making
community and making connections with
people i'm a people person
and one sense i kind of want to be my
own boss um and i
i've always had this thing to want to
become an entrepreneur but i've always
been afraid of it and i feel like
real estate it's not it just gives me
this
drive to want to be able to say hey i
can help people like myself who've never
had a home
and never see that come to life and be
able to be on the other side of that
very good okay well i think you should
do it
uh if i can figure out a way if i'm you
i'm going to do it incrementally not all
at once meaning not walk in and quit
your day job
so i would start talking to real estate
brokers in your area
and see if you can get on there's a lot
of
high production real estate agents like
the ones in our elp program that might
have a two
or three person team and they
one of those people might have an
entry-level position where you get
licensed
and you do some of the grunt work around
the real estate business and learn the
real estate business
working for them and that's your
that's your gateway into moving out on
your own eventually
okay but finding a broker that will let
you incrementally learn this
and some kind of part-time or joining a
team
for some kind of minimal guarantee while
you get your license and learn the
business
being mentored like an apprenticeship in
a sense if you can get engaged in
something that feels like that
then that's gonna do it the good news is
you don't have to sell a lot of houses
to make thirty four thousand dollars
so uh but but you're a long way i mean
you gotta get licensed
you've gotta learn a lot of stuff you
don't know today uh before that first
sale is going
to occur and so you need to get under
somebody's tutelage
and i can see where you would think i'm
just going to go out and start selling
houses
and there's a lot of things behind the
scenes that you just got to pick up
right
yeah and in this world today the
marketing in the real estate business is
not
it's not just as simple as saying what's
going
on
yeah there's a full you know digital
platforms there's
methodologies that you'd use for
gathering clients and communicating with
clients and
a lot of that costs money yeah and you
know getting plugged into that stuff and
learning how to do that in today's real
estate world
um you know a lot of people don't even
use a phone
you know they're just they're texting i
mean they use it for texting or email
and
but the number of times someone's
talking on a telephone
in our world today is a lot less than it
was five years ago
and that's certainly true even where
there's a lot of people interaction
um you know i bought a piece of real
estate uh
last week and i'm closing on it tomorrow
and um as an investment
and um i've not had a telephone
conversation
i won't be at the closing it'll all be
done digitally
uh everything will be wired you know and
that's a different world than when i got
my real estate license in 1978.
so those are the kinds of things you got
to be able to get your head around
if you're gonna move into this luca but
i think you should and could do it i
think you can do it don't you
got a special heart man absolutely and
uh
i love they don't they don't have a lot
of money they don't make a big salary
and they're still
cash flowing they're still grinding it
out he's got two little girls that
they're taking care of i just i love his
spirit and
man i got lucky with a uh real estate
agent with great character and i want to
see more of them out there so go get
them man
amen amen well that puts us hour of the
ramsey show in the books dr john good
job
james childs and kelly good work good
work we'll be back with you before you
know it
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i am john
deloney here with my good friend
best-selling author and pretty cool
person
mrs rachel cruz how are you doing great
john this is fun
we never co-hosted together this will be
the greatest hour in radio history
probably
hopefully or maybe not or maybe not hey
before we get going
what do we got going on friday yes we
have a fun event we just we did the run
throughs this morning for it
yes it's gonna be really fun it's gonna
be super fun money and marriage
and the live stream starts at 7 pm
central time that's right
friday nights this friday yes tomorrow
if you're listening live
uh and you can still get tickets right
now at dave ramsey.com
but yeah it's it's going to be a fun
event because these two
subjects in our lives are are huge right
like there's like
the the big parts of our lives our
health our kids but
marriage is always part of that
conversation money is always part of
that conversation so it's
uh it's gonna be fun and all over the
the
the country this year i've been taking
call after call about
man we've become great co-parents we've
been cr we've had to figure out
schooling from home working from home
all the stuff
man our marriage has gotten rocky it's
gotten messy right we've become
roommates
what do we do now right and you've been
talking to a person after person dealing
with
loss of a job furloughed unsteady income
so man we're going to join forces
superpowers to have a blast well what's
interesting too is i'm like
20 was a fascinating year because for
some people
yeah their marriages i mean they're
hanging on by a thread yeah you look up
you're like wow i actually don't like my
spouse and we're because we're forced to
actually see each other right all the
time or you got the election and they're
like
you believe what right in the same house
yes i mean all of that or i've talked to
some couples that have thrived
it's become the it's been the best ever
because they have had more family time
they've kind of re-established these
values in their homes like man i just
miss
this and so it's this wide spectrum and
the same with money
for some people they've been laid off
furloughed stressed out freaked out 40
of americans can't cover a 400
emergency in cash i mean like they're
struggling and they feel it
or some people they and they're in this
niche business and they've had the best
year of their life in their business
because
they make plexiglas or whatever their
thing is right right they're booming and
they they're all these revenues are
coming and they can't believe it so
it's i mean it's just like the spectrum
has been magnified
do you feel that way well it's yeah it's
it's almost uh everything's been put
under a microscope
and i we always say stress reveals
what your default setting is right i
don't say who you are because that's a
character issue but stress reveals how
you normally handle things do you turtle
up and just wait for the storm to go
over
or like the teacher we talked to that
just said enough's enough
and took on 47 jobs and yeah in new york
city right
and paid off everything and now she is
free and now she's fair
it's everybody responds differently to
your marriage when you realize
we're gonna be locked in a house
indefinitely right let's
let's make this awesome or do you
realize i i don't like you
right you you have to figure it out and
what's cool about friday night is we're
gonna be talking to everybody
right if you were trying if you're
hanging on by a thread and you
you feel there's only a few strings left
join us if you want to level up
like hey we found a new stride here we
want to run even faster
join us man it's going to be a blast
yeah that's going to be exciting
daveramsey.com to get your tickets
tomorrow night it's gonna be a hoot all
right let's go to lynn
in houston texas my hometown h-town
lynn what's going on hi i'm here with my
husband mitchell
hey yo are you are you guys setting us
up
yeah so we are married july
we're both 23. um and we have a question
sort of looking forward
into uh our future like in this three to
five years out and we're hoping to
transition into like the next phase of
life with me staying home
with kids we hope to have in the future
and we're just sort of
thinking about if there's like like
another savings account we need to have
at this point to start preparing for
that
to be saving for the kids um you know
honestly lynn no i think the fact that
you're thinking about it
and understanding okay if you want to
yeah once you have kids if you want to
be a stay-at-home mom obviously that
cuts your income
in half if yeah if one income drops and
so being aware of that so there's a
there's a
part that you're having this the dinks
the dual income no kids that you can
really get ahead i've never heard of
that a dink
nope never heard of the jinx my brother
has been a dink for a while double
income no kids
enjoy it learning new things on the dave
ramsey uh
so you guys can get ahead financially
with these two incomes coming in
but then yeah so take advantage of that
now is what i'm saying and then
once once whether you get pregnant you
guys decide to adopt however that
happens for you guys
once that process starts and then you
can say okay now let's look at our
lifestyle start to pan back and get used
to living the certain lifestyle with
this one income but i would not
necessarily have a separate savings
account right now um
but i think once that process really
begins you're pregnant or
adoption whatever that looks like that
begins then i would then i would kind of
bunker down and say okay let's start
cutting our lifestyle so we can get used
to it because there's me whiplash
with a baby and then whiplash with
dropping an income
and good for you lynn for y'all planning
ahead i don't
know many 23 year olds that think past
next tuesday so good for you guys man
that's incredible
i don't i don't know that i knew what
next week was going to look like when i
was 23. so good for them
all right let's go to christian in san
antonio christian what's going on how
can we help
hello how are you guys doing hi doing
great how are you
um miss rachel i don't know if you
remember who i am but i talked to you
back in march
um yeah you talked to a lot of people i
know um
i was the one about calling about how i
was so scared about covet and
me quitting for a semester and how i
wanted to you know fill up my emergency
phone does that ring a bell button yes
it does it does yes oh
well well hello hi i want to first of
all
i wanted to say first of all that i am
doing very well um
i don't know what the heck i was
thinking i let fear get over me
so uh get to the point right i uh i
actually not paid off my debt i am my
last semester
i paid off all my student loans i am
done no more debt i'm so happy
way to go amazing well done
yes yes and right now what i'm i listen
to your father i wish that he was there
but
you know i'm sure you can just pass the
message i decided to do a
uh doordash and i'm doing i'm doing
pretty okay but anyways but let me get
to the point right because you guys
have a lot of stuff to do so my question
for today is this uh for you
john and for uh rachel is that i know
what i have to do i read the book and
everything else
but both of you i do feel like
i've been feeling a little bit
overwhelmed because
uh i'm trying to get ten thousand
dollars for my emergency fund that is my
goal
and the thing is is that um with
everything that's going on
uh with me like say doing a 45 minute
workout
door dashing doing my school my problem
is that i have a lot of time but
i just have horrible time management um
i will admit that i have a problem with
procrastination
you know i'm putting things off and i
know it's important but i
tend to sometimes get a little bit
depressed and i get overworked and
you know i'm just wondering to any of
you like how can i make sure that i
don't lose steam because
yesterday literally was the day that i
just i did not do anything because i was
just so you know down the dumps
it's just one of those moments okay
chris hey we
yeah we have a hard break coming up but
i want you to stay on the line stay on
the line and we'll talk about it because
i think there's a couple of pieces
of this story that i think will be great
for those nurses that's great so hang in
there christian we'll be right back and
um
yeah you have some good stuff man we'll
get to you right here on the ramsay show
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people you know on the brink and
so it would have put us on the brink had
we not had
chm chm saved our life same document
financial lives
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget-friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm dr john
deloney joined with my good friend and
best-selling author rachel cruz and
we're taking your calls on life
taking your calls on money your
relationships whatever's going on your
life give us a shout at
825-5225 we are talking to christian in
san antonio
and christian has been busting it he has
been working
like crazy to get his is his school paid
off to get his
debts paid off and he's almost there now
he's working on or he's cleaned off his
debts now he's working towards an
emergency fund
and he's just sometimes running out of
steam is that right christian
pretty accurate yeah and so you're what
so what's your main question
how to better manage your time how not
to be a stress what
yeah what's your main question it is
more of just how do i
you know keep everything aligned i mean
uh i guess you can save the time like i
said before and i'll be honest in the
fact that
um i do have time um because i don't i
don't really have a full-time job it's
called part-time work but
you know from what they say is that you
know more time it seems that i tend to
procrastinate a lot
um hey christian why are you getting out
of debt why are you getting an emergency
fund like what's
what's the purpose the purpose well
mainly is to help my family out and i'm
not doing it for me i'm doing it more
for
you know my family to make sure that
save something goes wrong i can help my
you know my family out i would think
that's main the main reason
i just don't want to you know i don't
want my family to suffer
so if there's something that goes wrong
i have the money right there for and you
know it's less stress for the family
so and it will be a nice feeling to to
do it
i know that's another thing too if i got
to mention that
um always ask yourself why right you
know ask myself
why am i doing this i know that's a big
thing is
why i do things so christian i would say
on the money piece of this
we always say baby steps one through
three we we call it gazelle intensity
right which you have done i mean you've
been in school and you've still paid off
your loans i mean it's just unbelievable
so that
that is your intensity so any any moment
you have
um i would schedule your time
like you did your your debt snowball
like you scheduled exactly where your
money's going right your budget for your
money
you knew it was going you were
intentional you had a plan or you
wouldn't have paid off all that student
loan debt
in in less than a year so so you have
the intentionality bone in your body if
you will
so be able to use that towards your time
and to know hey
i'm going to be intense i'm still going
to do all my side work
if i have spare time you know i'm going
to still buckle down because your
your foot is too you know the pedals to
the metal if you will on those baby
steps one through three
and then knowing that end point whatever
that dollar amount is for your emergency
even once that's
completed then you can kind of take a
break off you know
put your foot off the gas and say okay
what else can i be doing with my time
but being able to
be constructive with your time
intentional with that and then knowing
yeah you're still going to stay intense
through baby step three and when it
comes to the personal stuff
i always want to make sure even when
you're running gazelle intense
you want to have people in your life
christian you want to make sure you're
spending time with folks even if it's a
few minutes even if you're working out
with somebody
even if you are choosing to have
stay-at-home dinners or lunches
invite somebody over if you can in texas
i think they're opening back
up i don't know if they ever even close
but you want to make sure you've got
people in your life
if you've got a lot of those thoughts
and you're alluding to man i just
start getting a little bit depressed i
don't want to get up i feel like i got
so much to do
make sure you write those things out
like you mentioned i love that idea
rachel of
almost like every thought almost like
every dollar right every thought budget
your thoughts out man and demand
evidence from them and if one of them
says
man you're not gonna get there you're a
loser you're exhausted
you can say nope not true and you can
move on to the next one and here's the
last thing
this is a not cool thing to say in
certain circles
but you got to sometimes do it when you
don't feel like it we let ourselves get
driven by our feelings sometimes in our
emotions and i'm just
don't feel like it today that's when you
really got to do it right if you got
that budget if you've got that time
budget you've got
that process budget then you're going to
look at and say nope i got to go do this
today i got to get that workout in i've
got to
i don't want to make my lunch today but
i got to make my lunch today you got to
make yourself do those things don't
forget to remember how good it feels
when you get to the end of a day
and you've got yet another victory
another small win so
christian you are crushing it man you
did so good since
march when you called last time you're
an inspiration to everybody man you can
make this work good for you we're proud
of you brother
all right let's go to sam in dayton ohio
sam what's going on
how's it going guys thank you so much
for taking my call thanks for giving us
a shout how can we help
um so i'm 25 and both my parents had
passed away
my mom passed away in 2015 and then my
dad passed away about three weeks ago
oh sam i'm sorry man
i appreciate that i've got a lot of
really good people around me and so it's
been a lot easier
to uh like you know handle this whole
crisis i know that you're saying to the
last caller that having people around
you is super important and i couldn't
agree more
i'm very lucky to have the friends that
i have um
uh to get to the point i am receiving an
inheritance from my dad
i'm not entirely sure how much it's
going to be
it's going to be between 250 and 400 000
dollars
27 000 of it is going to be coming to me
in the next few weeks and the rest of it
is tied up in the estate and it has to
stay open
in ohio for six months and
it's just it's more money than i've ever
had to deal with before or ever had the
opportunity to deal with because i
am very similar to rachel i'm a spender
and i'm not great at naturally saving
so i've been kind of an ish kind of guy
and i'm not in
really any debt i've got uh like a 2 000
medical bill
but that's it and i feel like this has
kind of given me an opportunity to
financially reset and do things the
correct way and i
know nothing about investing no nothing
about handling this sort of money and
i'm just
completely out of my league yeah well
it's a great question so
um so you said you have about a 2000
medical debt no other debt no student
loans car loans nothing
do you have any other do you have any
other savings
um i did before 2020. but uh i was the
little pig in the straw house so that
went away pretty quickly
for sure okay so what i would say sam is
that 27 000
you're gonna get pretty instantly and i
would go ahead just pay off the medical
debt and then i would set everything
else
in a money market account you can open
one on an online bank or a local bank
but it's it's going to get get you a
little bit better rate of return than
versus a traditional savings account
uh but usually with some money market
accounts at least mine i can say
you can't just use it as a checking
account you can't just continue to write
checks so you can write like two checks
a month or something so
it will help prevent you to spend it all
and it's in a separate account not your
checking so it's over here and i would
let that sit i would let that be your
emergency fund
and then when you receive everything
else
um it's gonna be like you said it it's a
lot of money
it's a lot of money and so i would have
someone in my corner
that can help me so we have smart
investor pros all over the country
and so i would really sit down with
someone interview a couple of people in
that investment world
and and find someone that has the heart
of a teacher not the heart of a salesman
is what we always say and that's so true
because you'll feel them like you'll sit
down sam and some guy will start talking
and you're like gross like he's just
gross right like you can just pick up on
people
he's just gross yeah i don't like him i
like him so so find someone that you
really really like
on a personal level honestly because
that's going to lead to say hey okay i
trust you
and you're doing all of this because
they are teaching you along the way
and so since you said i know nothing
about investing have them teach you and
say hey here's what a roth ira looks
like
hey your company matches okay well let's
put x amount up like
do different things um or have them talk
to you about different options
so that would be one thing i would do
and then do you own a home
are you um are you renting or do you
know i read
okay i rented i'm actually getting ready
to move across the country here once i
get this whole estate thing dealt with
oh wow okay perfect so i would wait
probably a year
in your new city wherever you're moving
before you settle down but you could
also use some of that
as um for a house whether a down payment
or not
and sam so as you cycle through this was
your was your father's passing
did y'all know it was coming was it out
of the blue
it was relatively out of the blue he was
in kind of
declining health he wasn't a big fan of
doctors and making sure to keep up on
his
health and so it wasn't completely
unexpected but the timing of it
really really was i had just seen him
like four days beforehand and had no
idea
oh wow well i you're gonna experience
this grief
with him being your dad with him being
your second parent this is gonna come
in in waves and in stages okay and so
you're going to wrestle with this you're
running on adrenaline right now
and over the next few months i love this
rule in ohio
i recommend nobody make any major
decisions
with this type of inheritance for three
to six months
to a year once you get that check you're
gonna have a whole
other wave of grief it's gonna there's
maybe some finality to it so make sure
you got people in your life
and then do what's gonna honor your
parents with this money
right is that going to be a home that
you pay for in cash is that going to be
setting yourself up down the road so
that you are completely taken care of
what is the thing that's going to best
honor your parents
take your time you're in no rush
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be
i'm dr john dolone joined here with my
good friend and best-selling author
rachel cruz and we're taking your calls
on life
and money give us a shout at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it's triple eight eight two five five
two two five
let's go to paula in santa barbara
california paula what's going on
hi uh thank you for taking my call thank
you so much for
for calling in what's going on how can
we help
um i wanted to see um if
buying property with my sister and my
parents
made um a land basically makes any sense
um my parents live with me and
they have just evidence of savings and
um
so they have like about a hundred
thousand and then my sister has about
that uh same amount and then i would
have to sell my house in order to come
up with that
same amount of money um and i have no
other debt
besides my mortgage and so
you know we've kind of considered
finding
land where we can all build and um
but i don't know if it makes any
financial sense i mean
um i know building is pretty expensive
um so you're talking about pooling all
of your money to buy some land you're
gonna make like a little family commune
basically yes will you own your own
individual
own individual portion of its paula or
are you guys gonna just own the whole
land together
well we we just talked about it so we
don't know what the right
um way would i mean if if there's any
way that we can actually make it work
we know that it has to be clear from the
part so that we don't have any issues in
the future which
basically i think would mean dividing
the land so that it's already
divided on the get-go i think so what's
driving this why do you guys want to do
this
well basically my parents the fact that
you know um
yeah they they don't have a place to
work
to retire and um my sister doesn't own a
home she runs where she lives and then
so i'm like the only one that has
um that owns a home and so
um that it seems like it could be
the best way so that we can all have
something
do you want to do this paula
uh yeah i mean because well i have uh
four kids and we have a three bedroom
so i'm hoping that we could you know
build a bigger house where
you know maybe even four rooms for my
kids to actually have a room and then
it just seems like it could be um you
know where we could actually have some
farm animals and stuff so
do you have them do you have the money
to go build a four bedroom house paula
no we don't we just have the money to
buy the land basically
yeah well from just the numbers you've
given and where you're at i don't
feel fine financially you're not you're
not there to a part that i would feel
good
advising you to say hey go and do this
step right now
um yeah santa barbara you're in an
expensive area
and your your sister's um
life and everything is is not your
responsibility
john can speak more into this right your
parents i know we all
respect and honor our parents and love
our parents and want to take care of
them
but there is something to be said to
paula that you have to make sure that
you're in a good spot
and that you and your kids are okay um
and for you that would mean
being completely debt-free having some
money in the bank for an emergency fund
and working on those basics is going to
be the best bet even though the house is
cramped i know it's stressful
um it's exhausting all of that but i
think you're going to put yourself in a
worse financial position
if you move forward considering you own
a home you don't have the money to build
one you have to sell your current home
to buy the land with your sister who has
doesn't have the money uh or she does
but she's renting and you know i mean
all of it
it's it's does not sound like the best
case scenario it sounds like one of
those ideas that got floated at dinner
and sounded like oh this could be a
solution
it's not a solution because nobody can
afford to do this your sister living in
apartment can't afford to
pitch in and buy property and build a
home on this thing right it's
it's a fantasy it sounds so cool and i
love
chickens i love goats and horses
whatever you want to put on your land
it sounds so fun um this is going to
turn into a nightmare
a secondary part of this question and
rachel you
you alluded to this man when you split
land with your family members we're just
gonna put in a big pot it's just gonna
be ours forever
right somebody gets married and that
husband always wants his other friend's
brother-in-law to come
hunt on that land or hey he's just going
to leave his dogs out here
it just gets messier and messy or they
move and want to loot
and they need that money so yeah i need
you to buy me both out both of you you
need to buy me out we can't afford to
and
so i'm going to rent it right it just
returns into a mess
and so love your family if you all want
to go in on a plot together great but
you gotta
everybody's got to have it deed it up so
where i
own this piece you own that piece and
you on that piece otherwise just set
yourself up for a mess
yeah and if you can afford it and this
is like the classic example of a home
it should be a blessing not a curse and
this is a situation that it's gonna end
up being a curse down the road
it's gonna be hard and bless you paula
you
your heart is so big we can we can feel
it here in nashville you got four kids
uh a small home your house is mayhem
right now and you're thinking
well i guess i could just figure this
out no
yeah that's not a good idea i love your
heart i love your family's heart this
isn't a good idea you all come up
something else
sorry to be the the bad guys here i'm
not sorry
i am i'm just too softy all right let's
go to will in oxford mississippi what's
up brother will how can we help
hey how are you good man um i was just
calling i'm 22 years old
um a senior in college now i'll be
graduating
in december and i'm currently a manager
at a retail store i'm making around
30 000 a year and um
i've gotten out about fifteen thousand
dollars in like
college loans and now i'm just paying on
college like as i go
and i've kind of read david's uh today's
book
the money makeover plan and um i've
saved about 7 000
for like an emergency fund so
i guess my question is what should i do
next
um i would hold tight well with that
seven grand
and i would pay do you have the money to
pay for falls
tuition because you're gonna be
graduating in december
that's kind of what i'm trying to wonder
should i stay for that now
yes and like just save up enough for the
next tuition year
exactly yes so you're gonna be working
your way through what i've been that's
what i've been doing
and that's great then that's great and
even will if you didn't even if you have
next month's tuition and you still have
that seven grand i would say pause
just pause everything while you're in
school you're doing great you're working
and you're saving that's all you need to
be doing because the best investment
right now
is in will so making sure you graduate
debt free is your number one goal
and then once you graduate then you can
be using that money you set up in
college to do
things like pay off any other debt that
you have
save up that emergency fund start
investing like doing that but while
you're in school
you just save and make sure you can pay
cash to go through school yeah that's
i i don't know a lot of college kids
that are
thinking how can i be getting the most
out of this money but rachel's right
well i mean
but that but an amazing question and
well done to you because most people
average has 36 thousand dollars in
student loan debt and they're just going
to be taking out more debt for next
semester but you're
working your way through you're doing an
amazing job good for you all right
rachel we're gonna
hit this one more time trying to find
the perfect valentine's gift
it is thursday and it's valentine's is
tomorrow
i'm sorry no it's this weekend i just
screwed that up it's coming
but we've got it for you i'm telling you
i got you girl man all right consider
this your friendly reminder in order to
make real progress with your money
you got to be on the same page as your
spouse which clearly i am
you need to work together to create a
budget and a plan that will help you
reach your goals
to help you get on the same page we
gathered up all of our best-selling
books
budgeting tools and bundles for couples
and all in one big sale so you can save
up to
83 on the gifts that will help you reach
your financial goals
folks this is the last week for the sale
plus you don't want to miss the big
money and marriage live stream event
that's tomorrow
with me and rachel rachel cruz the
we're going to have so much fun i can't
even wait visit us at daveramsey.com
backslash store to get your live stream
tickets your valentine's day gifts
that will help you build a bright future
for your spouse
hurry this sale ends on the real
valentine's day
february 14th but the live event is
tomorrow go get your tickets
daveramsey.com
i tell you what it's going to be fun
it's me awesome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scriptures from proverbs 16 16
reads how much better to get wisdom than
gold
to get understanding is to be chosen
rather than silver
sheryl sandberg says the ability to
learn is the most important
quality a leader can have i like that
the ability to learn is the most
important quality a leader can have
rachel how often do people get to the
top of wherever they think they're going
they get a leadership role
then they call it good oh yeah but you
know what it takes for that
is humility to say hey i don't have it
all like i
i need to learn huh right yeah we've got
all this the best leaders out there
it is but it's also the best husbands
and the best wives
and the best teachers and the best
professors and the best plumbers
everybody yeah it's when i get my
plumber license i'm done learning now
no man that just means you've crossed a
line on this journey that's the rest of
your life right
or we spend so much energy getting to
the wedding it's like man that's just
the start
you haven't even started playing yet
right you've both got a lot to learn
right
um i love that quote the ability to
learn is the most important quality a
leader can have that's awesome
continuing to learn
all right let's go to jonathan in
rochester new york jonathan what's going
on man
yes how are you guys doing today
outstanding what's up
great so i got a question so i graduated
from college in may of 2019
i've been working since and ever since i
was like 16 i've been given money to
my advisor and just straight mutual
funds um so i got
quite a bit saved up there i got about a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars
nice you had a mutual fund when you were
sixteen
yeah i started um my parents had an
advisor and i started going to him
and i just have listened to him since i
was a little kid because i figured
hell he's 20 years ahead of me and i
just said not
if he was in my position what do you
want me to do and i just always listen
to him
make sure you hug your parents every
time you see them okay
so yeah and then so um i still live at
home and my mom
just kind of told me that kind of a good
blessing they said that they want to
give me
two hundred thousand dollars to put
towards a home
is that their buy out is that their nice
way of saying dude you gotta go
yeah get out of the house right um so my
question
now so how obviously the housing
market's a little
hot right now so do i sell some of the
mutual fund and completely pay off the
house right i can probably get a really
nice house
here that i would really be happy in for
about 300. do i sell some of the mutual
fund to just
be totally debt free or house um free
yet
um like that or do i keep some invested
with a hundred thousand dollar mortgage
which i could comfortably afford to pay
um i don't know what you guys would
recommend jonathan any of the mutual
funds they're not retirement based right
it's not
it's not a roth or an iron straight up
broke it straight up brokerage fund yes
straight up brokerage one i don't have
any iras 401ks or anything like that all
my money
has been just in a straight brokerage
fund since i've been a kid
so if if you were to buy a two hundred
thousand dollar house what would that
look like
it wouldn't i would have to put some
money into fixing it honestly
no no it's fair i would need to spend
about 300 to be
something that i would be and and if i
do that i mean some of my buddies i mean
they're all roughly graduating now too i
graduated college in three years
so i had my year ahead of a lot of my
friends and a lot of them were saying
they would move in
so i mean i would wouldn't be covering
the mortgage by myself that's what i'm
trying that's why i
kind of yeah i don't know and how much
income and how much income do you have
how much do you make a year about 115
and 120
okay so honestly if ire jonathan i mean
either way
there's probably not a right or wrong
because you technically have the cash
just to go ahead and cash out the mutual
funds buy the house outright
and then you have the time you have the
time to invest
because of how young you are so to catch
up on any kind of compound interest
you're going to be able to do that
very very quickly so there's something i
love about the idea of having a paid for
home
jonathan 22 22 years old man and then
you have the rest of your life to invest
that's almost where i would go um but
you but knowing you have an emergency
fund and you do have some savings in the
bank
yeah i know i have emergency oh yeah i
do um and that's why the only reason it
was great is because like you can get a
rate for
two and a half three percent right now
and i know a typical mutual fund will
give me significantly more i know
yes yes totally to the math so if you
chose
so we say that a mortgage is the one
type of debt i won't yell at you for
and so yeah if you put down 200 get have
a hundred thousand dollar mortgage and
have the goal to pay it off in 18 months
and say and then you have the mutual
fund there all that it's just kind of
like
which way you want the the money to be
if that makes sense so there's something
i kind of love about the no risk no
debts
that's just fun for me i mean obviously
we're we're ramsey so we're going to
kind of
push the i love the no debt i love the
no debt idea
right because of how young you are and
how much time you have
left to invest and jonathan i moved to
nashville a few years ago and i didn't
have a mortgage until
recently and i can tell you at this
stage of life
i got two kids i'm married dude i want
no
i'm with rachel i would go into being my
23rd birthday owing nobody anything
with a 300 000 paid for house and the
rest i get the math and you wouldn't be
where you are if you weren't really
smart
and really savvy the challenge for you
is to
understand the wisdom of the psychology
of this not the math part
you've got the math part and you're
going to look at the the roi on
the interest rate versus this and i can
cover the gap there
i'm telling you right now there's
something to being completely dead
opening your own home
and there's a psychology to it man i'd
be that's that's right lean
absolutely congratulations man you were
way ahead of the game brother
amazing all right let's go to jacob in
seattle washington jacob what's going on
i just got engaged with my girlfriend
and
we are in the first stages of looking at
what to plan for budget for a wedding
congratulations man
any kind of guidelines or anything thank
you oh man you were talking to
two people who probably did this very
differently
number one jacob where are you guys
financially are you bringing debt in the
marriage you have any savings you have
cash who's paying for the wedding give
me a little background
so i am currently in baby step three and
i'm i
have just been lazy in terms of putting
my my money forward to getting through
my baby step three so i've got about
three thousand dollars
out of my three six months that's about
one and a half months right now for me
and then she has a ten thousand dollar
car debt and that's
it for uh okay that's awesome she makes
about
thirty five thousand dollars a year and
i'm about fifty five thousand dollars a
year
okay and who's who's responsible for
paying for the wedding
um it's gonna be solely on us my parents
have
shown interest in wanting to help but i
don't know what they're actually gonna
be able to contribute and i'm not really
expecting anything okay so
we're in february when are you guys
getting married
um we're waiting we're thinking about
maybe waiting until covet
is over but i mean that's kind of why
we're asking about
the budgeting and the the money work
like version of it so we can kind of
think where
we need to be in terms of how much time
we have to save up and what you guys
recommend for that so
i don't have a date or anything set okay
well i never
give a specific dollar amount by any
means or uh
or even a percentage so i i would say
for you guys what you can pause right
now
and if you just saved as much as
possible for the next
nine months whatever that would be um
and have that amount of cash there to
say okay we have the ability to spend
all of this on a wedding
or we can spend half of this money on a
wedding we can take the other half
and put it towards the 10 000 car loan
after we get married and pay off debt
and be in a better place financially all
of that so
the thing with weddings is you can go
real
expensive you can go real cheap we had
friends that got married during covet on
zoom they literally were like you know
what we're just gonna get past her and
they texted us like get on at 6 p.m
we're just gonna get married
and and i know that's not everyone's cup
of tea but part of me was like i kind of
love that like that oh man
yes that sounds incredible so just don't
go
just don't go crazy pay cash number one
and what you guys can say towards the
wedding
have that amount of money because you
can emotionally get attached to some of
that cash to say oh
let's not spend it all and just don't be
emotional about your decisions
yeah and also don't be afraid to get
married in a smaller ceremony
and a year and a half from now two years
from now when all the smoke is hopefully
clearing on all this
you can have the party of a lifetime
yeah don't wait on kovacs
you know what i mean if you love her
okay y'all just get married just do it
and then it's the year of 2020 2021.
you'll look back and tell your grandkids
yeah that's right it's a pandemic and
then
two years later i had the party of a
century that we paid for in cash it was
awesome
so you know what we were going to talk
about weddings you got saved by the bell
on that one rachel
you got saved by the bell maybe tomorrow
john i want to thank producer james
childs and associate producer kelly
daniel
thank you everybody for joining us join
us tomorrow night on the live stream
money and marriage go to daveramsey.com
to get your
tickets we hope to see you there it's
going to be a blast be kind to one
another
tell everybody that you know that you
love them and we'll talk to you soon
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you